[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام ارحب بكم معنا في هذه
الحلقه الجديده من البعد الاخر التي
يسعدني فيها ان استضيف مدير برنامج الامم
المتحده الانماء يا سيد اخي مشتاق سنتحدث
معه عن ملفات عده ابرز هذه الملفات
مشاركته مؤخرا في منتدى الرياض الثالث
للاعمال الانسانيه المنتدى الدولي طبعا
سنتحدث عن اوكرانيا سنتحدث عن الازمات
العالميه
وسنتطرق الى موضوع مهم كان في تقرير
برنامج الامم المتحده متعلق بالعنف
والارهاب في مناطق جنوب الصحراء في
افريقيا سيد اخي مشتاق ابدا معك بسؤال عن
مشاركتك في منتدى الرياض الثالث للمنتدى
الدولي للاعمال الانسانيه هذه المره
الاولى التي يشارك فيها شخص من برنامج
الامم المتحده الانمائي بهذا المنصب
الرفيع في منتدى انساني وليس منتدى تنموي
لماذا ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
هناك العديد من الاسباب اولها الدعوه التي
تلقيتها من مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه
والتعاون المتنامي بيننا وبين المركز ما
سمح بان يصبح جزءا من نقاش واسع حول كيفيه
استجابتنا للازمات والنزاعات جرت العاده
ان تركز الاستجابه للازمه الانسانيه على
انقاذ حياه الناس والاسعاف السريع سواء
كان زلزالا او حربا وازمه انسانيه
والنزاعا ولكنها بصفه متزايده اصبحنا نعيش
في عالم يشهد تناميا مضطردا للازمات والتي
نسميها الازمات الحمائيه حيث تتطلب تدخلا
سريعا لحمايه الاهالي حيث هناك الان ما لا
يقل عن 100 مليون شخص عبر انحاء العالم هم
اما لاجئون او ناجحون داخل اراضي دواليهم
ولذلك فان برنامج الامم المتحده الاملائي
هو اليوم جزء من برنامج الامم المتحده
للاستجابه للازمات ومشاركتي الاخيره في
منتدى الرياض الدولي للعمل الانساني هو
شكل من الاعتراف باننا نعمل الان مع بعضنا
البعض بشكل اوثق من اي وقت مضى بهدف
التكامل بيننا والتعاون بشان كيفيه
التعامل مع هذه الازمات المزيد من التعاون
بينكم بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه في حل
هذه الازمات
هذا جزء منها لدينا الان برامج شراكه
للتعامل مع ازمات ناشبه في عده دول ووقعنا
خلال زياره اتفاقيتين اضافيتين لتعزيز
تعاوننا وعملينا المشترك في اليمن لان ما
النتائج الحرب هناك اننا نشهد اليوم ضحايا
اكبر خارج ميدان القتال والنزاع من
اعدادهم على ما يدين المعارك سواء بسبب
الجوع او الاوبئه وعدم القدره على حمايه
الناس وهو من المتطلبات الاساسيه لايه
دوله ولذلك فان قدرتنا على تدريب الناس
على كيفيه التعامل وتجاوز هذا الظرف
الرهيب عبر حزمه خدمات نقدمها وهي جزء من
برنامج استجابه تنمويه طارئه نتعاون فيها
مع مركز الملك سلمان
بانه منع الازمات من الحدوث هل لاي احد
على مستوى العالمي القدره في منع الازمات
او هذا النوع من الازمات من الحدود
حسنا اذا كنت تقصدينا ذلك على وجه العموم
فانت محقه اذن لا توجد قدره لاي شخص لمنعي
كارثه وازمه من الحدوث لكننا تعلمنا
الدروس ما سمح لنا بفهم الازمات حيث لدينا
شيء نسميه عقدا اجتماعيا عندما تنعدم
الثقه بين الناس وحكوماتهم فلا يصدق هذا
الطرف والطرف الاخر بما يدفع الصعوبه الى
النائب عن مؤسسات الدوله فذلك يعني مبكرا
على كوننا في وضع يرجح فيه بصفه عاليه
تحدث ازمه او نزاع ربما بسبب تنافسا عرقي
او خلاف دينيه او خلافات تاريخيه بشان
الاراضي كل هذا يمكنك توقعه وبالتالي
التحذير منه في تقارير واقتراح حلول او
غيرها وقد
ركزت جزءا من مداخله في منتدى الرياض
الدولي الانسانيه على كيفيه التوقع بشكل
افضل اثناء الازمات الطارئه بما يسمح
بتجنب النزاعات وبكيفيه مبسطه جدا فان
الاستثمار في التنميه يبدو هو الوسيله
الانجح لتلف الازمات والنزاعات حيث يمكنك
دائما منعها كما انه ايضا السبيل الامثل
لتجاوز الازمات والخروج منها وهذا ما
يجعلنا نفهم ان انقاذ الحياه او مساعده
الناس على الخروج من الازمه ليس اهم من
منع حدوثها فقط والطريق على اسبابها افضل
ولذلك فان منح الحلول في الوقت الملائم
اهم حيث انه مثلا عندما توفر العداله بين
الجهات فانت ستكون قد تحركت بكيفيه مبكره
وملائمه بما ينزع فتيل الموقف اود ان
اسالك عندما تستمع الى تقارير تتحدث عن ان
حجم الانفاق العسكري في سنه واحده في عام
2021 بلغ
تريليوني دولار هذه الارقام الخياليه
عندما تستمع اليها بماذا تشعر
اشعر بالحزن وبالاحباط كما اشعر ايضا
باننا بذلك نهدر الكثير من الفرص تعرفين
انه على مدى التاريخ الانساني كانت هناك
حروب ونزاعات مسلحه لكن في القرن الحادي
والعشرين فان الامن البشري والامن السياسي
والامن الغذائي لا يمكنها ان تتحقق عبر
تسليح انفسنا فلا تعلم راينا ان كل
الاستجابات العسكريه للازمات والنزاعات
فشلت فقط انظري لمنطقه الساحل الافريقي
مثلا ففي السنوات الاخيره تم انفاق الكثير
من الاموال هناك في مهمات حفظ السلام ولكن
ايضا في برامج عسكريه لدعم القوى الخمس
الكبرى والان ها نحن في عام 2023 والوضع
اصبح اكثر تفجرا فالموقف في مالي وبوركينا
فاسو وكثير من دول الساحل صعب حيث يتنامى
التطرف العنيف ينبغي علينا ان نعترف انه
في بعض الاحيان جلب مزيدا من الاسلحه لا
يحل بشكل هيكلي المشكله لذلك فان العالم
في الوقت الذي يجد الاموال لشراء مزيد من
الاسلحه بما فيها الباهض جدا فانه يفشل في
ايجادها للاستثمار في التنميه رغم ان ذلك
يسمح بمعالجه مشاكل عدم التوازن في
الاستثمار والقضاء على الميزه الاجتماعي
والخلافات التاريخيه والاستثمار في
التعليم والبنيه الصحيه امور يعد الانفاق
فيها مجزيا وله عائدات اكثر على مستوى
الحلول اكثر من الوسائل العسكريه في
الورقه التي قدمتموها في المنتدى تحدثتم
عن طريقه
معالجه الازمات في المناطق اللي فيها
صراعات او المناطق الهشه
دعني اخذ سوريا على سبيل المثال سوريا لم
تخرج من ازماتها ازماتها متكرره بدءا من
الحرب والان الكوليرا
والزلزال ايضا اضاف الى هذه الازمات كيف
تستطيعون القيام بعملكم في ظل وجود كل هذه
الازمات في ظل جو يسيس كل شيء حتى
المساعدات كما لاحظنا مؤخرا
يقولون الكنانه في الامم المتحده سواء عبر
اميننا العام وزملاء العاملين في المنظمات
الانسانيه ولا سيما في برنامج الامم
المتحده الانمائي لدينا ايمان عميق باننا
موجودون هنا لنبقى في الشام فالامم
المتحده تعمل في بعض اصعب النزاعات واشدها
التعقيدا سواء في اليمن او ليبيا او هايتي
او لكن دعيني اكون صريحا في الموقف في
سوريا تكرر سواء عبر الجانب الانسانيه
والازمه عموما بان هناك مازقا سياسيا
وهناك استقطاب عميق جزء من ثمان ذلك ان
ازيد من 94% من السوريين يعيشون تحت خط
الفقر هذا ثمن باهض جدا اولا يدفعه
السوريون وثانيا اننا محدودون في التحرك
والاستجابه هناك مساعده انسانيه للسوريين
ولكن الى حد ما فبرنامج الامم المتحده
الاملائي يعمل لكن هناك عدد من الحدود
الصارمه التي سطرتها المجموعه الدوليه
والتي لا يمكننا التحرك خارجها ليس مسموحا
لنا المشاركه في اعاده التعمير فنحن نساعد
فقط في عمليات التعافيه المبكره وفي بعض
الاحيان علينا ان نتناقش بشان الاولويات
وان نختار بين ان ندعم عمليات التعافيه
المبكر او بالسماح للنساء بالتنقل داخل
وبين القرى والمدن او ان نشارك في اعاده
تعمير تلك المناطق هكذا وفي بعض الاحيان
كيف تعقد التوترات السياسيه عملنا ولكن في
النهايه نحن مؤمنون بانه وحتى نستمر باداء
اعمالنا في سوريا فان التنميه ينبغي ان
تكون جزءا من ذلك ولذلك على كل الاطراف ان
تتجاوز خلافاتها السياسيه وان تتفق على
الاولويات التي من مصلحتها كلها الالتزام
بها بما يقودنا في النهايه الى تعزيز
الامل في المستقبل في اماكن الفوضى كيف
يمكن لكم ان تقوموا بالتنميه يعني لن يكون
سهل على الاطلاق الوصول الى مرحله التنميه
في مناطق توتر اصلا
دعيني يشرح الامر كيف يمكن للناس النجاه
من الفوضى ليس بمقدور اي منه من يذهب الى
المدينه وان يقف في طابور انتظارا لتلقي
مساعده غذائيه عليهم ان يرعوا امورهم
الخاصه واولادهم سواء كان ذلك في
افغانستان اين عثرنا في خضم الازمه
السياسيه العاصفه على نساء نشانا مزارعهن
الخاصه ومشاريعنا صغيره بتمويلات بسيطه
وكل منهن ترعى بين سته وسبعه اشخاص ذلك
يسمح على المدى الطويل بانشاء شبكه
اقتصاديه على الصعيد الوطني تسمح للاشخاص
بان يتعايشوا مع الازمات ويخرجوا منها في
اطار يحافظ على كرامتهم حيث ينبغي مساعده
الناس على تجاوز الازمات ولا فانهم
سيستسلمون ما يزيد من تعميق الازمه
ويؤثرون على الدول الاخرى فيصبحون لاجئين
او نازحين داخل دولهم او على حدودها وقد
جربنا ذلك افضل مثال على ذلك اللاجئون
الصوماليون الذين يعيشون في كينيا في
مخيمات ولدت فيها جده وامهات وبنات ما
يعني ان ثلاثه اجيال وقعنا في شراك هذا
الموقف انه نزاع مثير للاسف جدا ومدان
بشده ولكن هذا هو الواقع وهو ما ينبغي ان
نذكر به الناس دوما هذه هي الحقيقه وهي ما
ينبغي ان نركز عليه ما هو الهدف الذي
تنوون تحقيقه في مثل هذه الاماكن التي
تعاني من عدم الاستقرار في المنطقه
العربيه
عندما تم تحديد مدن من سيطره داعش كان
برنامجنا وقتها يعمل مع الحكومه العراقيه
على برنامج استقرار رئيسي يتكلف مليارات
الدولارات ويضم الاف المشاريع الصغيره
لخلق الوظائف للاشخاص لتشجيعهم على العوده
الى كراهم ومدنهم التي دمرت جزئيا وتتضمن
دعم العوده بامور بسيطه مثل اعاده بناء
سقف او حمام منزل او اعاده ربطه بالماء او
الكهرباء او بكليهما لذلك فان الالاف من
هذه المشاريع بالتنسيق مع المجالس المحليه
والتجمعات المتضرره سمحت لما لا يقل عن
اربعه ملايين ونصف المليون كانوا مشردين
داخليا بالعوده في غضون سته شهور بعد
تحرير مناطقهم بدلا من ان يبقوا عالقين
لسنوات في مخيمات هذه هي الصوره التي توضح
معنى التدخل العاجل الناجع والبعيد عن
البيروقراطيه والتي سمحت عبر برامج عمليه
لملايين الاشخاص باعاده بناء تجمعاتهم كل
شخص يرغب بالعوده الى دياره لكن اذا لم
يكن لديك مدرسه او كهرباء او ما او
الاساسيات التي تسمح لك بالعيش فانك لن
تعود برنامج الامم المتحده الاملائيه
وقتها بدعم من الاسره الدوليه والسلطات
المحليه ايضا وخاصه نجح في احداث فارق
هائل وهذا هو تحديدا ما نرغب بجلبه
للمناطق التي تعيش ازمات ونعمل الان في
المنطقه في دول مثل اليمن وفي لبنان الذي
يعيش وضع اقتصاديا حرجا للغايه اين نساعد
مؤسسات الدوله هناك على الحفاظ على
وظائفها الاساسيه بما يساعدها على اداء
مهامها في العراق نجحنا بعد النزاع الاول
في احداث الفارق وامنوا ان يستمر البرنامج
في العمل مع الدول المجاوره التي ترغب
برؤيه جيرانها لا تعاني من مثل هذه الظروف
نحن شريك موثوق وكفر نعمل تحت مظله الامم
المتحده على ضمان ان لا تتعقد الاوضاع
اكثر اسمح لسيد سنذهب الى فاصل قصير بعد
ان نفتح ملفين مهمين ايضا الحرب في
اوكرانيا وملف التطرف مشان الكرام فاصل
قصير نعود بعده لمتابعه البعد الاخر ابقوا
معنا
وارحب بكم معنا مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
واهلا بك معنا من جديد سيد اخي
ودعني افتح معك الملف الاوكراني حرف
اوكرانيا
سببت مشاكل على المستوى الانساني على
المستوى العالمي كيف تنظرون لهذه الحرب
اولا نحن ننظر الى المناطق التي تضرر فيها
الناس اكثر مثل موجه اللجوء الداخلي
الملايين فروا الى خارج البلاد ملايين
اخرون نزحوا داخل بلدهم لذلك تعين على
برنامجنا النظر في كيفيه دعم الحكومه
الاوكرانيه على الاستمرار في اداء عملها
فيما هي تحت الهجوم والقصف جزء مهم من
الدوله ما زال يعمل بما يعزز قدره الحكومه
على استخدام الوسائل التكنولوجيه الجديده
لاعاده تسجيل الناس في مؤسسات الامان
الاجتماعي التي تديرها وايضا القدره على
ان نمول المؤسسات الصغيره مثل المطاعم
العمل وايضا النازحين على اطلاق مبادرات
صغيره تسمح لهم بتثبيت انفسهم في مناطق
عيشهم الجديده ومره اخرى يتعلق الامر
بالحفاظ على الكرامه في تسيير شؤون الحياه
وليس
رهنها بالاخر وفي نفس الوقت على قدره
الحكومه على العمل ومعالجه اثار التدمير
والقنابل والعبوات والمتفجرات التي تم
تركها وهنا يساعد برنامجنا الحكومه على
التعامل مع هذا الامر وخلال شهور الاخيره
اصبحنا احد الوكالات الرئيسيه الشريكه
للحكومه في التمويل السريع لاستبدال
التجهيزات المتضرره في منشات الجهد العالي
مثل مولدات الكهرباء في المدارس وغيرها من
المباني التي كانت عرضه لقصف ممنهج استهدف
بنيه الطاقه في اوكرانيا لذلك كنا من
اوائل الممولين بما منح القدره لاوكرانيا
على اعاده بناء بنيتها الكهربائيه بسرعه
لان ملايين الاشخاص غير قادرين على الحصول
على الكهرباء لعشر ساعات او اكثر يوميا في
الوقت الرهن ولكن كما تعرف الحرب في
اوكرانيا اثرت على كثير من دول العالم
كيف يمكن ان تخرج الدول التي تاثرت
بالتداعيات بشكل مباشر من ازمتها
على سؤال هل هناك وسيله سهله لمعالجه
التضخم اسعار الطاقه والغذاء ولكن ايضا في
اسواق المال ونسب الفائده التي تتزايد
بكيفيه متضاعفه وقيمه راس المال في الدول
التي تقترض الاموال من الاسواق الدوليه
والتي يتعين عليها خدمه الدين لذلك فان
المستهلك يدفع اكثر والحكومات تدفع اكثر
للوفاء بمواعيد الدفعات وهناك اموال اقل
تحت تصرفها وتصرف مواطنيها انها ازمه
تكلفه معيشه والامين العام للامم المتحده
عند اطلاق برنامج عالمي للتعامل مع هذا
الوضع العام الماضي اطلق مبادره البحر
الاسود الكبرى بهدف تهدئه اسواق الحبوب
العالميه والتي تعد المنطقه اكبر مزودا
لها ايضا نحن بصدد مساعده الدول التي
تاثرت وتعاني من ازمه ماليه حاليا وفي
سياق اجتماع مجموعه العشرين ولكن مؤخرا
اطلق الامين العام ايضا خطه تحفيزا
بمشاركه مجموعه العشرين وايضا مؤسسات
التمويل مثل صندوق النقد والبنك الدولي
للتوصل لاساليب اسرع وانجح في مواجهه
الازمات في الدول المتعثره او التي تواجه
صعوبات في الوفاء بديونها فهناك 150 دوله
تعاني بشكل او باخر من الديون وهناك منها
من هو على بعد خطوه من الافلاس لذلك تتم
مناقشه الضخ السريع بالسيوله واعادتها
هيكله الديون وايضا اعاده التفاوض بشان
شروط هذه الديون بما يجعل الدول تدفع اقل
فحرب اوكرانيا مست مئات الملايين من البشر
عبر العالم حسنا اول شيء هو الاستثمار
والوقايه وحل الازمات مهم جدا هناك من
يجادل بان الحرب حتميه اعتقد انه لا يوجد
امر لا يمكن تجنبه عندما يتعلق الامر
بالجيو سياسيه لكن لا يمكننا دوما ايقاف
الحروب يعني من ان تندلع ولكن يمكن القيام
بالكثير لمساعده الناس على مواجهه
التداعياتها ينبغي الاستثمار في السلم
والامم المتحده تلقت الكثير من الانتقادات
بسبب عدم منع الحروب من الاندلاع ولكن في
مثل هذه الازمات نحن نحتاج لدعم الاسره
الدوليه وايضا اطراف الحرب للنظر في اسباب
استمرارها وكيفيه ايقافها في المنطقه
وايضا على مستوى العالم ولسوء الحظ يبدو
انها لن تنتهي عما قريب
لا يمكننا توقعها وحتما لكل منا وجهه نظره
لكن الدبلوماسيه دور مهم جدا حيث يمكن
التوصل لمكان يكون مهيئا بكيفيه
معها الاطراف بالتواصل مع بعضها البعض
هناك حروب استمرت لسنوات بل وقود وانا
اصلي حتى لا يكون نفس الامر بالنسبه الى
هذه الحرب لان الثمن باهض بكيفيه
استثنائيه بالنسبه الى الاوكرانيين وروسيا
ولكن ايضا للعالم كله وخاصه العالم السائر
في طريق النمو فبعد الخروج من ازمه كورونا
يبدو العالم مرهقا بفعل ضغوط تلك الازمه
والان مع هذه الازمه الثلاثيه في الطاقه
والغذاء وقيمه راس المال والقروض نحن ندفع
الكثير من الدول السائره في طريق النمو
الى مصير سيء وحرفيا الى الافلاس ولا يمكن
لهذا ان يكون الحل لهذه المشاكل في القرن
الحادي والعشرين واحده من الاشياء التي
كانت ملفته للنظر في تقريركم الحقيقه
الحديث عن التطرف والعنف ذكرتم في التقرير
ان الاسباب ربما او الدوافع لا تعود
لاسباب دينيه انما تعود لاسباب اقتصاديه
بالدرجه الاولى خاصه
افريقيا وجنوب الصحراء كيف تفسر لنا هذا
ما هي مقاربتكم
حول كيف يمكن منع النزاعات ومن الدروس
التي تعلمناها انه في دول مثل جنوب
الصحراء التي اصبح فيها التطرف احد ابرز
عوامل عدم الاستقرار في الساحل ولكن ايضا
في اجزاء من موزمبيق وفي غربي افريقيا
هناك ظاهره تبدو فيها مجموعات تعتقد في
التطرف العنيف بصدد التسلل في عده دول
ونعرف مبدئيا ان مشاكلها مثل الفقر وعدم
المساواه وعدم قدره المؤسسات الحكوميه على
العمل انتجت فراغان سمح لهذه المجموعات
بان تجد موتا قدم لها بل وان تجند عده
اشخاص ونحاول ربط العلاقه بين كل هذا ففي
عام 2017 نشرنا استطلاعنا الاول حول مقات
السابقين تم تجنيدهم من قبل مجموعات
متطرفه وقد وسعنا هذا العمل الان ونشرنا
التقرير الثاني بعد ان قابلنا فيه اكثر من
الفي شاب تم تجنيدهم في ثمان دول على
امتداد منطقتي الساحل والقرن الافريقيين
وطرحنا عليهم سؤالا حول ما الذي دفعهم الى
الانضمام الى هذه الجماعات هناك كانت هناك
خلاصات مهمه جدا الكثير من الناس كانوا
يعتقدون ان الرساله الدينيه كانت عنصر
الجذب الاول عند الانضمام الى هذه
الجماعات لكن في الواقع عندما تتحدث للناس
صغار السن فن العامل الاقتصادي والوضع
الاجتماعي هما العاملان الاهم مثل البطاله
وعدم توفر متطلبات الحياه او الفقر المتقع
هذا هو الدافع الاول وليس الدين في
الحقيقه ما يمثل المشجع الاول ثانيا عرفنا
ان التعليم ايضا عامل مهم فعندما تستثمر
في التعليم فانك على الاقل ستنقذ 13% من
هؤلاء المجندين
اشار الكثير منهم الى حوادث قادحه كانوا
على علاقه بها ادت بهم الى الالتحاق بهذه
الجماعات مع ضلوع قوات الامن والجيش في
التعامل مع تلك الحوادث التي تسجل فيها
انتهاكات لحقوق الانسان ترى فيها والدك
مثلا يعتقل او شقيقك يصاب او يعتقل دون
اذن قضائي لكن هناك ايضا غادروا هذه
الجماعه ترغب بذلك لاسباب مختلفه يعودون
اليها لان وعودا قدمت اليهم لم تتحقق لذلك
فقد اتاحت لنا هذه المقابلات التعرف على
اسباب انضمام هؤلاء الصغار الى هذه
الجماعات وايضا ما يمكن القيام به لمنع
ذلك لان تداعيات هذا على بعض الدول تعد
كارثيه انظري الى مالي او بوركينا فاسو
فقبل عشر او خمسه عشره سنه كانت الظروف
مهيئه لهما للبدء في طريق الازدهار والان
هما تعانيان من اجل الحفاظ على القدره على
اداء الوظائف الاساسيه المنوطه بالدول هل
تعتقد بان التنميه قد تكون بديل عن التسلح
او عن الاسلحه
نحن بصدد تعلم كيفيه التعامل مع هذه
الظاهره اولا عبر توطيد عوامل الاستقرار
مثل ما فعلنا في العراق لان في منطقه
الساحل ينبغي البدء بالتجمعات المحليه
بدلا من العمد فرؤساء مجالس المحليه
فالمحافظين والسلطات المحليه يحاول ان
نعيد لهذه التجمعات الاسباب التي تجعلها
مقتنعه بصواب الاستمرار داخل الدول عبر
توفير سوق او مركز امن وبنيه للتعليم
والصحه بما يجعلك تستعد ثقه الناس
وايمانهم بقدرتهم على اعاده بناء تجمعاتهم
بما يضع حجر الاساس لدوله تعمل من جديد
وتوفر الامل لمواطنيها وتمنعه من الابتعاد
عنها بسبب عدم وجود مركز شرطه نظام للقضاء
ما يستدعي الجماعات المتطرفه للقدوم لتوفر
لهم حسب عقيدتها ادارات محليه من ضمنها
الحفاظ على الامن والقضاء بين الناس وفقا
لمعاييرها لذلك اعتقد اننا تعلمنا عده
دروس على مدى السنوات الاخيره ابرزها
ضروره اعاده بناء المؤسسات واقامه انظمه
القضاء والامن وتوفير الفرص الاقتصاديه
لذلك نعمل مع السلطات المحليه وخاصه
الزعماء المحليين وقاده التجمعات لانهم هم
من يعرفون حاجاتها وبجزء بسيط من الاموال
صدقا التي تنفق على مهمات حفظ السلام
والامن يمكنك اعاده خلق فرص التنميه وهذا
هو السبيل لقطع الطريق امام التطرف العنيف
من جهه وايضا اعاده الامل للناس باستعاده
الثقه في مستقبل دولهم مجددا اشكرك يا
جزيل الشكر سيد اخي شتاينر مدير برنامج
الامم المتحده الانماء للمشاركه معنا في
هذه الحلقه من البعد الاخر وبهذا مشاهد
الكرام انتهت هذه الحلقه يمكنكم دائما
متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر فيسبوك ويوتيوب كما يمكنكم الاستماع
الى حلقتنا على العربيه بودكاست الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]